Secretary of amus has basically forced
his immigration policy on the country
against the laws passed by Congress and
the result has been thousands of dead
Americans human trafficking cartels
we're going to look at the facts and
make a decision on whether or not he
should be impeached House Republicans
putting immigration front and center
with a planned hearing this week
doubling down on their push to impeach
DHS secretary mayorcas over his handling
of the crisis it comes as mayorcas
visits eagle Pass Texas tomorrow where
more than 12,000 migrants illegally
entered the small town of 30,000 in the
last week of 20123 alone coachi County
Arizona Sheriff Mark Daniels joins us
now Sheriff thanks for being with us
this morning you know thanks for having
me we do this story I think I I've been
out to your county in the past and I was
looking at the numbers Sheriff it's
almost we remind the public we talk
about this story and yet it doesn't
cease to be stacked staggering just a
few short years ago something like half
a million we're up to over 3 million in
a fiscal year it it's I know you see it
on the ground what do you make of what's
happened in a short amount of
time well let me just say this about
secretary my orus when it comes to it
there's two things I look at anytime
that somebody's put in a position of
leadership number one is is his
leadership working are people following
him and I'll just say this I have yet to
find a customs or board Pro agent to
walk up to me or work with me and say
Sheriff this is working secretary my
orcus in fact if you took a poll within
CBP it'd be uh it' be damning to the
reputation of secretary Marcus second of
all sheriffs throughout the country have
a vote of no confidence against
secretary Marcus based on his lack of
action based on his policies and that's
why you see the Border in what it is
that's why the sheriff stood up on that
second of all this is some we we we
forget he took an oath of office similar
to I did and that is to protect our
communities to protect our country you
got to ask a question has it been
successful and we all can agree no it
has not and last not least well I'll say
this to you and to the viewers today is
the fact that yes he owns his decisions
but we own the American people own his
reputation and that's not a good one to
have right now so you said two separate
things I want to follow up on first of
all the violation of his oath and and
that seems to be a topic where we could
talk about the effects of uh an
impeachment but the first thing you had
to say is whether or not it's working
and I guess I would only challenge you
in this
respect it depends on what you're trying
to accomplish and and that's more of a
political decision or a political
question than it is a competency
question because this is at such a high
level of incompetency Presumed in
competency that it's almost hard to
imagine so you'd say well this is
actually the purpose it is working to
fulfill a political goal that is above
mayorcas so what would impeachment
actually accomplish this is a decision
from an admin Administration level and
he might be doing a bang up job of
accomplishing their
goal you're you're har correct on that
the intended consequences is what we're
addressing today and this starts with
President Biden let's not even forget
that but either way he took an oath to
protect the Homeland that is his job
description that is his oath he set that
aside he set America aside for political
values and ideology over the people
that's why I say he failed and so then
therefore the is back to your your your
oath uh and you you brought it up again
which I think is a propo is that's a
question not just for mayorcas but for
Biden in defending as you mentioned your
community and our Constitution and
lastly before I go very quickly just
give me an update on the on the on your
community like what has changed over the
last couple of years since I've been to
coochi
County well well it's a slippery slope
since you've been here we we'll take
back the visit you had here about a year
and a half ago compared to where we're
at today last two years we booked
2,884 people in my jail for Border
related crimes that'll cost a 9.3
million dollars to the taxpayers just on
Border related crimes for international
crime for people committing crimes next
to the Border it is a traged happens
every day Public Safety National
Security and humanitarian we see it
every day yeah I I know that you do and
I know that it's only metastasizing
despite the best efforts of sheriffs
across this country it'd be nice to I
think it would be nice have somebody
who's interested in actually correcting
the problem not just failing to but
interested in trying to correct the
problem Sheriff Daniels always great to
see you thank you I'm Steve duy I'm
Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis